foreign
I was born and raised in Caracas
Venezuela back in the 80s and 90s
Venezuela is a beautiful country rich
with natural Treasures from beaches to
rainforests but one thing that people
don't quite realize is that we also have
really tall mountains these are part of
the Andes and they stretch all the way
down from Chile and Argentina and
they're also home to some of the very
few tropical glaciers in the world
back in 1910 when the first map was
drawn Venezuela used to have five
tropical glaciers which we used to call
the five white Eagles
today unfortunately there's only one
left and it covers an area which is
smaller than Central Park in New York
City
these glaciers have been disappearing
because of the use of a resource that we
strike not too far from them
oil
Venezuelan my relationship with all is
complicated
on the one hand only three source that
help my country develop as well as human
civilization
on the other hand is a resource that
slowly but surely fuel an existential
threat climate change
we now know that's what bear the worst
impacts of climate change we're going to
have to decarbonize everything that we
do and everything that surrounds us and
to do that within the next three decades
these include things like transitioning
from oil natural gas to clean sources of
electricity
electrifying all of our vehicles
rethinking the way that we make our
buildings and cities
the good news is that Technologies do
some of these things already exist
and legislation to frame and direct
these efforts is starting to be put in
place
the bad news is that even if we do all
of these things it will still not be
enough
there's still large sectors of our
economy that will need to be
decarbonized for which we don't have the
technology yet
these include the things like
manufacturing processes that are used to
make everything that surrounds us
from the cement and steel that holds our
buildings together to the chemicals and
materials that we use to make the goods
that we use in our daily lives
things like the chair that you're
sitting in your shoes the cars that you
use and all the devices that we use
every day
the chemical manufacturing industry
alone accounts for 10 percent of the
energy consumption
and 20 of the carbon emissions from
industry
these emissions arise from the use of
fossil fuel combustion to generate the
heat that is required to drive processes
inside of our old and inefficient
chemical plants
one way to start fixing the issue will
be to use electricity instead of heat
from fossil fuels to dry the processes
inside of these plants sounds easy
enough right just unplug the natural gas
pipelines plug in the electrical wire
and make sure that your Source
electricity from clean sources like
solar wind or nuclear
unfortunately in reality is much harder
than that we're gonna have to come up
with new chemical reactions that can
Source their energy directly from
electricity
these are called electrochemical
reactions and is what my research group
at New York University is focusing on
figuring out electrochemical paths that
can create direct links between clean
electricity and molecules
in electrochemical reactions heat is
replaced by electricity as an energy
source this allows us to operate
reactors and Carry Out reactions at room
temperature with minimal energy losses
but the problem is that for
electrochemical reactions to become
viable they will need to be more
efficient and cost competitive than the
heat power ones that we use today
that means that electrochemical reactors
will need to transform
raw materials into products very
efficiently with minimal ways and very
selectively
this will then in turn incentivize
chemical manufacturers to switch to
electrochemical production processes
instead of deploying new fossil fuel
chemical plants
in our research we started by looking at
a chemical reaction that is used to make
one of the most important polymers in
the world Nylon 66
more than 5 million tons of all kinds of
nylons are produced every year
and out of those two million tons are of
nylon 66.
and these are used to make things like
the textile fibers that we use in our
winter jackets
or the plastic car parts that help make
our vehicles lightweight and fuel
efficient
through our research we managed to
identify electrochemical reaction
mixtures with the right additives and
voltages to be able to transform raw
materials into nylon precursors very
selectively we achieve selectivities of
more than 80 percent a value Addison par
with commercial reactors but we didn't
stop there
what most electrochemical reactions
operate with a constant stream of
electrical currents we knew that if we
control the interactions between the
electricity input and molecules which
could achieve a higher performance
to do that we decided to start exploring
different electrical pulses in the
search for the right pulse sequence that
will deliver electrons at the same rate
that molecules could react
since there were so many pulses that we
needed to test we decided to then use a
few number of results from different
poses to train machine learning models
that then help us identify the
appropriate pulse sequence for this
reaction
this was the first time that artificial
intelligence was used to optimize an
electrochemical reaction and the pulse
sequence that we discover allow us to
increase by 30 percent the production
rate of these reactors
these large improvements in efficiency
selectivity and production rates are
very important because they will ensure
that electrochemical reactions are
competitive with fossil fuel power ones
which are already highly optimized
but hey nylon is only one molecule in a
network of tens of thousands of chemical
products many of which you see in this
diagram and many of which which are
common occurrence in your daily lives
just think of the Plastics that are used
to make your computers and phones or the
pain that covers the walls around us
or the medicines that help us live our
healthy lives
we're gonna have to decarbonize it all
within the next 30 Years
that means that we're going to have to
discover develop and deploy chemical
processes much faster than we did in the
past Century
to that end my group at NYU is combining
artificial intelligence with autonomous
research tools to run hundreds to
thousands of experiments per day in this
way we hope to decrease the time from
idea to Discovery by more than a hundred
times
Beyond nylon we're also looking into
production processes to manufacture
other chemicals like ethylene and
propylene these are the main precursors
to most of the plastic in the world
through electrochemistry we have managed
to Electrify already the most energy
intensive steps on the production
process of these chemicals a set of
processes that alone account for a very
substantial amount of energy in the
chemical manufacturing industry
we're also rethinking the way that we
make our chemicals and the chemical
Supply Chain by developing new processes
that can use and transform food waste
into the chemicals that we make today
from oil
this can be done by extracting molecules
from waste streams and using them as
precursors to things like Plastics
additives cosmetics and pharmaceuticals
and many more
and in this way enhancing sustainability
in chemical manufacture even further
the chemical industry is Central to our
modern economy and to our ways of lives
decarbon isonate will take us several
decades this will include things like
retrofitting our chemical plants so they
can use electricity directly capturing
and sequestering CO2 as it comes out of
the gas flow stacks and more importantly
developing new chemical processes that
are more efficient and can Source
electricity directly from clean sources
by accelerating researching
electrochemical manufacturing my team
aims to develop some of these reactions
and in this way help to transform the
chemical industry one reaction at a time
when we get there we will have been able
to erase the carbon footprint of the
chemical industry
and we won't be able to bring our
tropical glaciers back we will have
helped to develop a sustainable path for
the future of our planet thank you
[Applause]